jean christophe lagarde merci d'être
avec nous en direct sur rt france alors
pour commencer votre réaction aux
derniers chiffres annoncés en disait 471
décès ces dernières 24 heures plus de
4500 morts au total-- pour la première
fois un chiffre sur les personnes
décédées dans les ehpad qui s'élève à
884 à quel est votre état d'esprit ce
soir je crois comme tous les français
les grainage de ces de ces chiffres jour
après jour sont à la fois effrayant
meurtrissant et nous attendons de les
voir baisser alors ils ont beaucoup
augmenté au cours de ces dernières
semaines il continue à augmenter mais
moins vite ce qui semble montrer que
finalement comme l'expliquent le
gouvernement comme l'expliquent les
milieux médicaux celles et ceux les
soignants qui sont en train de essayer
de sauver le maximum de vies
c'est en restant chez nous qu'on
arrivera le mieux dans un premier temps
en tout cas à combattre le drame de
cette épidémie de cet ennemi d'épidémie
pour la france mais pour l'ensemble du
monde
ces chiffres il blesse il meurtrissent
ils font peur
il fait peur et je crois que la
population française a de plus en plus
peur mais c'est aussi ce qui permet que
chacun puisse être raisonnable en aidant
de soignants en restant chez soi en
dehors bien sûr de ceux qui sont
nécessaires pour faire fonctionner le
pays
nourrir la population garantir les
services publics les plus essentiels et
moi je veux rendre un hommage
particulier aux agents des collectivités
locales qui continue à travailler pour
que le pays ne s'effondre pas derrière
les soignants il ya aussi les policiers
les gendarmes les agents des
collectivités locales les caissières de
supermarché les gens qui mettent en
rayon qui continue à nous faire vivre et
si ces chiffres sont effrayants
ils doivent d'autant plus vous donnez
une énorme reconnaissance vis-à-vis de
tous ces français qui sont comme on dit
en deuxième demie mais en réalité font
vivre chacune et chacun de ceux qui sont
confinés
on va y revenir effectivement tout à
l'heure notamment dans votre
circonscription 510 maisons
un mot sur la mission d'information hier
avec edouard philippe et olivier ferrand
vous y avait un participer selon vous
est-ce qu'ils ont répondu correctement
aux problématiques comme l'absence de
masques de médicaments encore la
question des tests aux problématiques
c'est une chose mais aux questions oui
manifestement et moi j'ai été président
j'ai voulu créer j'ai été président
d'une commission d' enquête sur le h1n1
souvenez vous il ya une dizaine d'années
où justement nous avions préconisé qu'on
ait des stocks de masques considérable
on avait eu jusqu'à presse d'un milliard
et demi de stocks de masques et puis en
une décision absurde folle dangereuse
dont il faudra un jour examiner les
raisons a décidé qu'on aille plus loin
un masque et qu'on comptait sur la chine
pour en produire si un jour on avait un
problème
l'exact inverse de ce qu une commission
parlementaire que j'ai prié avec jean
pierre door par ailleurs été le
rapporteur avait préconisé et donc on se
trouve aujourd'hui démunis de masse
c'est pas la peine de se payer de mots
judge affirmant si le mastodonte donc la
priorité a été donnée aux soignants pour
permettre que en plus de la pénurie de
masques on se retrouve face à une
pénurie de gens capables de soigner les
malades et notamment les formes le plus
grave c'est ça ce qui est en train de se
passer
alors le gouvernement répond avec les
moyens qu'il a puisque il n'a pas
inventé créé des masques tout seul dans
son coin il essaye d'en acheter comme
tous les gouvernements du monde et j'ai
trouvé finalement que les réponses
étaient à la fois sincère franc
j'aimerais y compris et c'est sans doute
l'élément le plus important à comprendre
pour tout le monde quand le premier
ministre explique qu' il ya des choses
qu'on sait sur ce virus sur cette
pandémie et il ajoute c'est là tout on
ne sait pas tout est effectivement qu
avez vous pensé d'ailleurs de cet aveu
du premier ministre je pense que c'est
sérieux
nous vivons sans doute à des moments les
plus graves que l'humanité a connu plus
de la moitié de la population plus monde
est confiné et il n'y a que quelques
gouvernements encore pour nier ou
essayer de minorer la gravité des choses
et donc que le premier nice 10
il ya des choses qu'on sait et sur celle
là on a quelques certitudes on peut agir
il ya des choses qu'on ignore encore et
ce n'est pas la peine de mentir aux gens
la crise est suffisamment grave nous
suffisamment pardon dans la difficulté
pour ne pas les employer un autre mot
pourtant en plus mentir et donc il dit
voilà il ya des choses dont on n'est pas
encore certain qu'on ne sait pas y
compris scientifiquement les
scientifiques les médecins il ya un mois
il ya un mois et demi
n'annoncez pas une crise d'une telle
gravité eux mêmes pensées faisait la
comparaison avec la grippe on a été un
certain nombre moi le premier à
reprendre cette comparaison
bah c'est pas ça mais il ne savait pas à
l'époque
il ya des choses qu'on sait aujourd'hui
qu'on ne savait pas hier il ya des
choses qu'on ne sait pas aujourd'hui
qu'on sera demain il faut et le
confinement sert aussi à ça protéger les
soignants ne pas mobiliser lampes au
talent de l'hôpital mais laisser le
temps aux scientifiques aux chercheurs
de nous trouver des remèdes et des
vaccins et ça ça dépend de la
responsabilité de chacune et de chacun
d'entre nous jean christophe lagarde
comme ça pour laisser le temps à ceux
qui savent de colette de comprendre de
découvrir et aussi de participer à une
sauver jean-christophe lagarde vous en
parliez un la question des masques
objets de toutes les convoitises
à ce sujet je voudrais vous faire
écouter renaud muselier c'était lundi
sur notre antenne le président de la
région paca a affirmé que des américains
avaient acheté une commande française
sur le tarmac en chine
je vous propose de l'écouter puis on
écoute votre réaction les masques seront
fabriqués et en attente
aujourd'hui en chine des difficultés que
nous rencontrons c'est l'acheminement et
nous devions en avoir lâché dément pour
deux soirs dans cet acheminement goût
méfiants parce que nous avons eu des
pressions de france est en fête avec la
femme des prud'hommes région commandé
près de 60 millions de marks pour nos
régions respectives
sauf que ce matin lors de sur le tarmac
en chine une commande française a été
achetée par les américaines cash sur le
tarmac et l'avion qui devait hier en
france est partie directement en aux
états unis donc que devant ces problèmes
large sont en train de sécuriser la la
la marchandise de façon à ce que il ça
passe par ces vagues et la filiale
mondiale dépendant de ces menaces et gm
qui est le troisième armateur mondial de
façon à ce que le train de marchandises
ne soit pas saisie ou achetés par
d'autres sur le tarmac et donc je vous
donnerai exquise dans le courant de la
semaine
alors cette lutte intransigeante menée
par les américains pour obtenir du
matériel de protection elle vous inspire
quoi est-ce que cela devrait être
contrôlés ou bien c'est la loi du marché
d'abord elle m'inspire deux choses nous
avons des présidents de région je pense
à renaud muselier je pense à valérie
pécresse qu'on sache trentenaire bref
qu'ils sont en train de faire le maximum
avec la puissance financière qui est la
leur la capacité de commandes très large
pour essayer d'aider à approvisionner la
france pendant que le gouvernement
essaye de faire la même chose
c'est une très bonne chose et on doit
les en remercier et cuir derrière on a
un problème
en règle générale avec les américains
d'abord parce que donald trump comme
boris johnson comme ce dingue de bolton
arrow au brésil qui continue à
considérer qu' à rien et qui se passe
rien on dit de nant tout ça c'est pas
grave n'y aura pas de problème etc
et c'est sans doute aux etats-unis
comprises que le plus grand effondrement
sanitaire le plus grand nombre de morts
est le plus grand effondrement
économique
alors pour se rattraper avec l'agilité
et souvent le mélange entre la politique
et l'argent qui existe aux etats unis
ils sont effectivement avec des
pratiques indignes dans ces périodes de
crise d entrain d'essayer ici et là de
racheter voire trois fois quatre fois
plus cher c'est ce qui expliquait encore
ce matin renaud muselier en cash
là où nous on respecte des règles et il
faut les respecter
donc ça m'inspire comment des âges le
sel que c'est pas parce que les états
unis sont présidées par quelqu'un qui
n'a pas pris conscience de la gravité de
la situation
ils doivent maintenant essayer de se
rattraper avec le dollar sur le reste du
monde
mais ce qui compte pour ce qui nous
concerne c'est à la fois d'arriver à
sécuriser nos approvisionnements venant
de chine
faut pas que la chine soit incapable un
pays communiste dirigiste très étatisée
donc il est capable de diriger les
commandes et de ne pas laisser ce genre
pratique se dérouler si le président
chinois le thread et que nous on soit
capable de multiplier les commandes
partout dans le monde et y compris par
la production française mettra du temps
évidemment inventé en charge mais elle
commence à monter en charge que ce soit
des masques en papier comme ceux qu'on
voit l'image que vous diffusez que ce
soit des masques en tissu réutilisables
qui sont aussi ce qu'ils respectent un
certain nombre de là une forme de
solution que nous pourrions produire en
france
alors pour terminer une dernière
question vous êtes député de sainte cène
de seine-saint-denis vous avez parlé de
l'importance du confinement tout à
l'heure sur votre département
et justement montré du doigt par
plusieurs élus pour le non-respect du
confinement la maire pcf d'aubervilliers
a elle même déclaré hier sur public
sénat avec il y avait trop de monde
dehors elle a regretté que l'état est
annulé le couvre-feu instauré dans sa
ville quel est votre point de vue
justement sur cette situation dans dans
ce département de seine saint denis côté
bois comme tous les français j'essaye de
m'astreindre au confinement même si mes
fonctions mais m'amène à me déplacer de
temps en temps et donc tout ce que je
vois ce débat aubervilliers qui est pas
si loin de 5 chez moi mais c'est ma
ville de drancy c'est les villes qui
sont autour de moi
et j'observe c'est le constat des
préfets du préfet c'est le constat de la
plupart des élus que contrairement à ce
qu'on raconte à la télé dans les milieux
bien pensants le confinement est
globalement bien respectée je ne suis
pas sûre qu'il soit moins bien respectés
rieur je ne suis pas sûr comme l'a dit
le premier ministre est fière que tous
ceux qui ont profité de leur résidence
secondaire pour partir à l'île de ré ou
ailleurs qui ont de ce fait contribué à
diffuser leur et le virus dans la nation
soient les mieux placés pour fantasmer
sur ce qui se passe ici c'est vrai que
c'est plus difficile pour une famille
qui vit à cinq ou sept personnes dans un
deux pièces de rester confinés mais
j'observe que les policiers nationaux
comme les policiers municipaux quand il
contrôle les gens qui sont dans la rue
quand on regarde ce qui se passe devant
les magasins
y a des dès que de dizaines et de
dizaines de mètres ce qui pose la
question de la réouverture des marchés
d'ailleurs la réalité c'est que ces
gens-là ils ont le papier il en droit
d'être dehors et je vais vous dire je
suis passé dimanche un peu partout dans
ma circonscription il y avait presque
personne dehors
alors évidemment il ya toujours de 3
abrutis mais je suis pas sûr qu'il soit
quand cette année qui suit qui peuvent
être dehors cela l'un d'entre eux dans
ma ville qui a été attrapé pour la
sixième fois dehors et maintenant en
délit et partira en prison
la cré l'écrasante majorité de la
population un policier venise et 97 %
des gens qui sont contrôlées sont en
règle et ils sont pas si nombreux que ça
dehors par rapport à l'habitude merci ce
que je veux dire à l'ensemble des
journalistes qui commande c'est fait on
a dit on va regarder la preuve que la
seine-saint-denis est inciviques
bref que les pauvres où les jeunes sont
ainsi rick c'est à dire qu'ils sont
abrutis qui préfère mourir ça ce qu'on
est en train d'expliquer c'est que les
hôpitaux ont explosé eh bien je leur
demande de faire le boulot et d'aller
regarder les chiffres
pourquoi effectivement les hôpitaux de
seine saint denis ont été rapidement
complet c'est parce qu'il ya moins d
d'hôpitaux en scène ça me convient moins
de policiers en scène sonic comme ya
moins de d'enseignants en
seine-saint-denis il ya un rapport
parlementaire qui avait montré tout ça
donc si on est arrivé plus vite au
plafond c'est parce que le plafond était
plus bas message entendu merci merci
jean christophe lagarde d'avoir répondu
à nos questions j'appelle pouvait être
président de l'ue pays député de la 5e
circonscription de seine saint denis